en 1944 la France est occupée par
l'armée allemande pour l'affronter les
Alliés cherchent donc à ouvrir un front
en Europe occidentale
à ce moment là il y avait des Allemands
qui étaient gentils plutôt bien
finalement mais quand les SS sont
arrivés alors là c'était fini
salut les épicurieuses et les
epicurieuses si je vous dis Normandie
vous pensez peut-être aussi vrai
et au camembert tout cela évidemment ce
sont des clichés la Normandie regorgent
de paysages uniques en France d'animaux
surprenantes et de plages chargées
d'histoire elles ont été le théâtre du
fameux débarquement le 6 juin 1944 dont
nous fêterons le 80ème anniversaire en
2024 pour nous guider aujourd'hui j'ai
fait appel à mon ami Bruno maltor il est
déjà sur place
[Musique]
le débarquement s'est déroulé ici dans
la baie de Seine entre la Bretagne et le
détroit du Pas-de-Calais plus exactement
entre les ports de Cherbourg sur la
pointe du Cotentin et Le Havre dans
l'espoir de la Seine les Alliés
cherchent donc à ouvrir un front en
Europe occidental leur choix se porte
sur cinq plages de la côte normande cuta
gold Juno Sword et Omar c'est non ne
figurez pas sur les cartes de l'époque
ces plages ont été renommées par les
Américains
Omar par exemple est le nom d'une petite
ville d'une Nebraska ce choix est un pur
hasard au moment de baptiser l'opération
un officier a demandé à deux
sous-officiers d'où ils étaient
originaires l'un d'eux a répondu
Omar et c'est justement sur cette plage
que nous attendons
[Musique]
hello les amis hello à tous oui je suis
sur la plage d'Oma actuellement je peux
dire que ça fait vraiment quelque chose
d'être ici regarde
il faut imaginer ce qui s'est passé ici
le 6 juin 1944 une armada de 6900
navires 130 000 hommes et 20000
véhicules s'approchent des plages c'est
l'opération Neptune le prévu de la
Bataille de Normandie cette bataille va
durer deux mois va commencer donc sur
les plages avant d'aller sur les terres
et ça va permettre d'ouvrir la voie à la
libération de l'Europe occidentale ceci
étant dit une fois que les soldats
alliés sont arrivés ici ils sont bien
rendu compte qu'ils allaient devoir
grimper ce qui était derrière moi et
évidemment cette tâche elle était très
périlleuse
[Musique]
j'ai enfourché mon vélo Jamie direction
la pointe du Hoc par la voie verte et
c'est magnifique
même s'ils sont surpris les Allemands se
sont préparés à cette attaque avec le
fameux mur de l'Atlantique bien qu'ici
nous ayons les pieds dans la Manche en
1944 selon les informations des alliés
les Allemands ont installé de puissants
canons à la pointe du Hoc c'est un lieu
stratégique car il est situé entre Omar
et Yuta d'ici en théorie les Allemands
peuvent donc arroser toute la zone où
les Alliés ont prévu débarquer pour
réussir le débarquement il faut donc
neutraliser ce poste de défense
regardez partout autour de moi sur le
plateau il y a 10 monstres qu'on peut
voir et ben ça ce sont en fait les
impacts laissés par les bombardements
des bombardiers alliés dès avril 1944
ils vont chercher à neutraliser les
fantassins et les artilleurs allemands
afin de faciliter le débarquement
malheureusement ça va pas se passer
comme prévu ils vont pas être très
précis au niveau des tirs et du coup les
canons seront quasiment en état intact
les amants vont retirer les canons à
plus de 1000 mètres de la Pointe du Hoc
et pour l'anecdote les canons vont être
remplacés par des canons factices en
bois
mais ça les 225 rangers du
lieutenant-colonel rudeur qui débarque à
la pointe du Hoc au matin du 6 juin
l'ignore totalement pour eux la tâche
s'annonce très très difficile
il suffit de regarder où je me situe
actuellement pour comprendre un petit
peu le contexte je suis au sommet de la
Pointe du hocke à 30 mètres au-dessus du
niveau de la mer les Américains une fois
qu'ils vont arriver vont devoir grimper
cette falaise de différentes façons
d'ailleurs avec des grappins avec des
échelles et même pour certains avec des
poignards ça va leur prendre une bonne
dizaine de minutes mais une fois arrivé
en haut ça s'est pas très bien passé
pour eux pourquoi parce qu'en fait il y
avait plus de 100 artilleurs allemands
qui les attendaient chargés de défendre
leurs zones
leur centre opérationnel le voici c'est
le poste d'observation panoramique et il
permettait aux amandes observer toute la
mer je peux vous le dire c'est du solide
il tient encore debout d'ailleurs ce que
je vous propose c'est qu'on aille tout
de suite à l'intérieur
les Allemands appellent ce poste
d'observation d'un régulateur c'est un
bunker muni d'ouverture qui permet de
surveiller l'arrivée de l'ennemi mais
aussi de positionner des hommes armées à
l'époque il y en avait plusieurs sur la
pointe du Hoc qui était reliés entre eux
par des galeries souterraines
suivez-moi on va rentrer dans le bunker
donc comme vous pouvez le voir on
arrivant il y a des escaliers assez
étroits il faut pas être trop grand non
plus et on va arriver dans un sas il
s'agit d'un sas de décontamination prévu
pour parer les éventuels attaques au gaz
donc on a conçu dans chaque bunker un
sas de décontamination de ce type
ils avaient donc plusieurs fonctions
c'était conçus pour éviter les attaques
au gaz ou encore les obus d'ennemis mais
ça fait aussi par exemple de centres de
communication ou de centres de stockage
de munitions c'était aussi tout
simplement un lieu de vie pour les
hommes oui Jamy ici les hommes vivaient
de 24 heures sur 24 je suis dans un
dortoir qui pouvait accueillir jusqu'à 9
allemands comme tu peux voir il pouvait
y avoir ici des lits superposés en
journée ils étaient collés contre le mur
tandis qu'en soirée via les chaînes et
les crochets on pouvait descendre les
lits en tout cas une chose est certaine
c'est quand même pas très grand et dire
que tout ça a été fait sous la
contrainte et construit par les ouvriers
français et les prisonniers de guerre
mais au petit matin du 6 juin 44 les
Allemands n'ont pas de loisir de faire
la grasse matinée dans leur bunker ils
sont pris au saut du lit et oppose une
résistance farouche à leurs assaillants
la bataille ne dure que 20 minutes à
l'issue desquels les Allemands doivent
rendre les armes en s'emparent de cette
position les américains découvrent alors
que les canons ont été déménagés une
opération qui a malgré tout tué ou
blessé 135 des 225 Rangers qui ont
débarqué ici
c'est pour ça que la pointe du Hoc et
aujourd'hui un haut lieu de mémoire ici
au sommet du bunker d'observation on
peut voir un Rangers monument mais c'est
pas sûr qu'on puisse observer encore
très longtemps et les falaises de
Normandie sont très fragiles et sont
victimes notamment de l'érosion
et la pointe du York n'est pas épargnée
en 2010 le Congrès américain a débloqué
la somme de 4,8 millions d'Euros pour
renforcer la falaise et prévenir son
érosion tout comme les cimetières
américains de Colleville la gestion du
site est confiée à l'américaine battle
monument commission l'organisation
américaine en charge des sites de
mémoire
pourtant ces travaux n'ont pas permis
d'éviter les fondement d'un temps entier
de l'épre rocheux ici en mai 2022 et
comme tu peux le voir Jamie c'est
vraiment impressionnant les éboulis ont
déjà été emportés par la mer
normal en Normandie les falaises de
craie sont fragilisés par les
infiltrations d'eau de pluie les
épisodes de gel et des gel et bien sûr
par le mouvement des vagues qui
grignotent inexorablement leurs pieds
ces phénomènes sont parfaitement
naturels mais ils sont aggravés par
l'urbanisation et par le changement
climatique les pluies et les tempêtes
qui sont de plus en plus violentes
depuis quelques années font de très gros
dégâts les falaises cette en moyenne 10
à 15 cm de terrain par an sur le
littoral donné en Seine-Maritime le
département le plus touché par les
submersions marines un million de mètres
cubes de roche disparaissent chaque
année
en tout cas c'est très émouvant de
parler des gens qui ont changé le cours
de notre histoire mute si jamais il n'y
a pas que les pierres qui parlent ici en
Normandie on va partir ensemble
justement dans l'Orne afin de rencontrer
une femme extraordinaire qui a vécu
plein de choses dont le débarquement
quand on parle de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale on évoque souvent les
débarquements en Normandie puis en
Provence et la libération de Paris mais
on oublie souvent une autre bataille
tout aussi décisive celle de la poche de
Falaise Chambois dans l'Orne 2 mois
après le débarquement les Allemands
n'ont pas tous été délogés de Normandie
à Falaise Chambois un groupe résiste les
Alliés encerclé alors l'armée allemande
au total 250
000 hommes s'affrontent sur seulement
quelques kilomètres carrés et bien c'est
justement sur ce champ de bataille que
nous retrouvons Bruno
oui Jamie je suis dans les terres entre
Argentan et Vimoutiers et je viens
d'arriver plus précisément au Mémorial
de Montormel où je vais rencontrer la
fameuse personne dont je t'ai parlé un
peu plus tôt elle s'appelle Daniel et en
1944 on était encore qu'un enfant
bonjour Daniel vous êtes normande non
parisienne ça commence bien je suis né
dans Paris 14e
c'était en 39 donc je vais avoir 94 ans
et les enfants à la déclaration de la
guerre ils ont été obligé de partir en
province d'accord j'habitais ça
s'appelait la rue Brette c'est derrière
le château ça s'appelait les abattoirs
il y avait des Allemands là et le père
de mon ami d'enfance on a été en
poussette ensemble il était directeur
des abattoirs et nous on allait jouer
dans les abattoirs et à ce moment-là il
y avait des Allemands qui étaient
gentils et le matin il nous donnait des
œufs à la coque du chocolat ça se
passait plutôt bien final mais quand les
SS sont arrivés alors là c'était fini
après donc on est parti de Falaise on
est le long des routes c'était sympa
la vision des adultes qui devaient être
morte de trouille mais moi j'étais comme
ça un endroit que je me rappelle on dans
un champ et il y a des Allemands qui
sont sortis
d'un bois d'une haie quelque chose et
ils l'ont pris à partie les jeunes et
parce que les jeunes leur avaient dit
vous êtes foutu enfin voilà ils ont
condamné à être fusillés et donc ils ont
obligé nous les suivis à regarder et moi
je me rendais pas compte mais toute les
grandes personnes étaient mortes de peur
et comment ça s'est passé justement la
libération ensuite c'était la joie tout
le monde était là tout le monde était
content j'avais même une poupée qui
avait des drapeaux français américain
anglais en chiffon OK et j'ai mangé mon
premier chewing-gum j'ai avalé
transmettre aux jeunes générations
on voit la guerre en Ukraine mais vous
avez pas l'odeur vous avez pas les
bruits vous avez pas les cris des gens
qui sont là vous savez que encore
maintenant il y a une bête crevée dans
un coin ou autre chose je le sens c'est
rester dans la tête et qu'est-ce qu'on
peut trouver dans ce musée c'est la
mémoire c'est important pour tout le
monde je trouve que c'est important pour
l'épée actuellement c'est mal parti
quand on va à gauche à droite la vie
humaine elle vaut pas grand chose
actuellement
merci beaucoup je crois que c'est tout
c'est déjà pas mal voilà merci beaucoup
[Musique]
la mémoire entretient la mémoire pour
éviter de reproduire les erreurs du
passé autant que faire ce peu allez
maintenant direction la côte cette fois
Bruno se dirige vers 40 ans une petite
ville située dans le département de la
Manche on oublie la guerre pour une
excursion sur le chenal de 40 ans il
s'étire sur 7 km avant de rejoindre la
mer déjà arrivé Bono
[Musique]
ouais Jamie je me trouve plus
précisément sur le port de 40 ans il y a
de superbes bateaux autour de moi comme
tu peux voir alors je te rassure j'ai
pas aller sur le drake norbiking pour la
petite balade qu'on va faire ensemble ni
sur la barge qui la rescapé du
débarquement américain mon bateau c'est
celui-là et je vous présente les deux
capitaines Michel et Sami on y va on y
va
[Musique]
alors notre première étape c'est un pont
canal assez unique en songe j'ai
l'impression comment ça a été construit
alors c'est l'ingénieur Charles Lamine
qui l'a mis au point bien sûr il a créé
il a été créé quand finalement ce pont
là il a été inauguré en 1994 ça
correspondait avec le 50e anniversaire
du débarquement donc c'était c'était une
grande fête locale bon en tout cas Jamie
j'ai pas mal voyagé autour du monde et
je crois que j'ai jamais vu ça et si tu
le regardes d'en haut ce fameux pont
canal ça ressemble à une coque de bateau
inversée alors pourquoi ici l'eau pastel
au dessus de la route et non l'inverse
pour l'harmonie du paysage bien sûr mais
surtout parce que de nombreux voiliers
qui sont à quel dans le port de 40 ans
en train de ce chenal pour rejoindre la
mer si l'on avait construit un pont
classique suspendu au dessus du chenal
il aurait fallu construire un édifice
très très haut pour que les mares ne
heurte pas le tablier du pont alors
qu'avec un bon canal on ne se pose plus
la question
alors j'ai l'impression qu'on enchaîne
les découvertes sur l'appel de 40 ans
parce qu'on est arrivé à une écluse ça
c'est l'écluse de 40 ans ou le sas quoi
voilà de mise à niveau et ensuite on va
aller vers le canal qui va vers la mer
et il paraît aussi qu'il y a des phoques
dans le coin normalement il y a des
phoques normalement
[Musique]
voilà Michel j'ai l'impression que les
paysages ils ont bien changé on est à la
BDV c'est ça on arrive dans la BDV et la
mer est forte aujourd'hui donc
du coup on pourra pas voir les phoques
aujourd'hui c'est la nature aussi hein
voilà aujourd'hui on verra pas
si vous voulez
il y a pas de problème
[Musique]
installer dans la baie de V il y a un
peu plus de 30 ans en provenance d'une
importante colonie qui se trouve dans le
sud de l'Angleterre c'est une espèce
côtière qui aime les eaux froides et
tempérée on reconnaît l'espèce grâce à
sa tête plus large et plus ronde que
celle des phoques gris et honnêtes
décrochement entre la tête et le museau
avec une paire de jumelles on peut aussi
observer que ces narines forment un V
Jamy je crois que j'ai trouvé un phoque
où c'est une maison
regarde la nuit on peut voir tout là-bas
la pointe du Hoc et Utah Beach au final
c'est ce que les héros du débarquement
ont pu voir le matin du 6 juin 1944
c'est ce que je t'ai montré au début de
la vidéo au final la boucle et ben elle
est boucler à bientôt
merci Bruno et j'espère que cette
découverte de la Normandie vous a plu et
qu'elle vous a permis de mieux apprécier
la richesse historique et les paysages
de cette région si vous avez aimé
n'hésitez pas à liker à laisser des
commentaires et à vous abonner à la
chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà fait avec
Bruno nous vous donnons rendez-vous très
vite pour de nouvelles découvertes je
vous souhaite une excellente semaine à
toutes et à tous et à dimanche prochain
pour de nouveaux savoirs épicurieux
[Musique]